if you don't like playing symetra an
overwatch that might change soon I'm
Tony and this is your supportive
gamespot news update director Jeff
Kaplan sat down to talk about all the
big changes for symetra the most notable
is a second ultimate she'll still have
her handy teleporter but you'll be able
to choose between deploying that or a
shield generator that continually buffs
your teammates she's also getting a new
photon barrier ability this is a moving
bubble that makes for a fine substitute
for ride hard shield if you don't have
him on your team as for her current load
out all her gear is getting tweaked her
teleporter will have more health plus
shields that regenerate over time she
will also start each round with six
turrets instead of the current three and
her primary beam fire is getting an
extended range these buffs will be
available on blizzard's public test
realm soon Blizzard is constantly
tweaking overwatch so expect more
changes before the new symetra is
released to the public the team is also
working on a new map called Oasis
currently planned for release in early
2017 to keep up with all the latest from
overwatch you're already in the right
place
you
you